The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
I'm in a very good mood today.
It's nothing to do with the
class, but I'm having a baby.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: So that's
kind of exciting.
So if I just started
giggling, you'll know why.
And in six months if I am just
weeping and on the ground,
you'll also know why.
So today we're going
to do two things.
The first is I'm going
to give you-- well,
the first is review a
little bit of practice
for the exam we're going
to have on Thursday.
So let me tell you a little
bit more about the exam.
The exam, by the way, has been
rescheduled to be in the 6120,
not in Walker Gym.
So it's going to be the usual
place, we're not moving.
And the reason is I'm changing
the format on this exam,
in part to make it a little
less of a burden to everyone.
But also in part because
I've been struggling
with the question of how to
make the exam most useful.
The purpose of an
exam like this is not
to get grades for you
guys, although that's
an incidental byproduct.
The purpose is to give you
some feedback on how you're
doing, how your command of
the material has evolved.
And also to help you
learn some of the things
that you might
not have mastered.
So the way the exam is
going to be structured
is going about 15 minutes
of short answer questions--
a couple of very short
computations but mostly short
answer questions-- on paper.
You'll hand those
back, and then we'll
go over those questions
in class afterwards.
So it's a relatively
low pressure exam
and it's mostly conceptual.
It will cover everything we've
done through this last problem
set to the degree that we get
to the lecture part of today
after questions.
Today's lecture will
not be directly covered,
however it will be fair game
for the next midterm-- which
will be more of a
traditional midterm--
and that's coming in April.
So the structure
of today is, I'm
going to give you a whole
bunch of clicker questions.
So make sure you've
got your clickers out.
And those clicker
questions are going
to give you a sense for the
level and scope of the exam.
The exam will be a little harder
than the clicker questions,
but not a whole lot.
And the difference
is just that it's
going to be on paper in front
of you instead of clickered.
And thus, that gives
you a little more room
to do calculations on a piece
of paper, short calculations.
And then after that we'll come
on to-- in some sense a review,
but also an introduction to
the Dirac Bra-Ket notation
that many of our
textbooks use, but that we
haven't introduced
in lectures so far.
Any questions before
we get started?
AUDIENCE: What channel are we?
PROFESSOR: 41.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So no practice exam?
PROFESSOR: I think
there will probably not
be a practice exam because
of the shift in format.
Today will basically
be your practice exam.
If I can get my work
together and get
you guys a practice exam of
the right format, then maybe.
But it wouldn't be all
that useful is the problem.
So watch what happens today.
AUDIENCE: Will you post
the clicker questions
from today and the last
time on the website?
PROFESSOR: I will post
the questions from today
on the website, yes.
AUDIENCE: So it's 50
minutes, short answer.
Is there a certain
number of questions
that's going to be on it?
PROFESSOR: I'm not
going to tell you that.
But it's not going
to be a time trial.
You're not going to be
racing to get the, you know.
AUDIENCE: Will it still be
worth as much as an exam?
PROFESSOR: It will.
Because to my mind,
part of the reason
to design the exam
this way is that it's
testing your conceptual
understanding, which
is the important thing.
So it will be.
Other questions?
All right.
So let's get started with
the clicker part of today.
So we're on channel 41.
So consider this
eigenvalue equation,
two derivatives on f-- it's
constant-- times f of x.
How many of these
are eigenfunctions
with the corresponding
eigenvalue?
You've got about 10 seconds.
So go ahead and
put in your clicks.
And so your-- whoops, oh sorry.
That just cleared your
responses, unfortunately.
Don't worry, they're
saved in memory.
It just cleared
them off my screen.
So the responses-- here we go.
Oops, that didn't work.
Wow, it just totally
disappeared out of that app.
Wow, that's so weird.
Oh no, that didn't work.
Let's try this.
Where did it go?
Ah, there it is.
Whoa, this is all
very confusing.
So that was your response,
B and C, 63% and 38%.
So let's go back to this.
Quickly discuss this
with your neighbor.
And now go ahead and
click in your new answers
if you-- you can keep
talking, that's fine.
Another five seconds.
Awesome.
OK, that's it.
So the answer is B. And
99% of you all got that.
I suspect someone didn't click.
OK good, next question.
Psi I and Psi II
are two solutions
of the Schrodinger equation.
Is the sum of the two of them
with coefficients A and B
also a solution of the
Schrodinger equation?
Oh, and I forgot to
start the clicky thingy.
So click now.
AUDIENCE: Did you mean to
say B Psi 2 on that thing?
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah, it is
supposed to say B Psi 2.
It says B Psi 2 on
the next-- sorry,
it's A Psi I plus
B Psi I. It should
say I Psi I plus B Psi II.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Does it mean
that the same Schrodinger
equation with the
same potential?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, with
the same potential.
Yeah, Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Wow, Yeah.
So you know Einstein said,
God didn't play dice.
And let me paraphrase
that as, God doesn't
mess with you in
clicker questions.
And you guys have effectively
universally that the answer
is A, yes,
superposition principle.
OK next question is going to
be for answer-- here we go.
Consider an infinite
square well with width a.
And compared to the
infinite square well with A,
the ground state
of a finite well
is lower, higher, same
energy, or undetermined.
You've got 10 seconds, so
continue thinking through this.
5 seconds.
OK, and you mostly
got it, but have
a quick chat with the
person next to you.
All right, let's try again.
Such a good technique.
All right, another five
seconds to put in your answer.
4-3-2-1.
And you virtually all got
it right, a lower energy.
And let's just think
about this intuitively.
Intuitively, the gradient of the
potential is the force, right?
So in the second case,
you've got less force
cramming the article
inside the box
so it's being
squeezed less tightly.
More physically,
you see that there
is an evanescent
tail on the outside.
What that tells you
is the wave function
didn't have to go
to zero at the ends.
It just had to get small and
latch onto a dying exponential.
That's from the qualitative
analysis of wave functions.
But meanwhile,
what that tells you
is, it has to curve less inside
in order-- it doesn't have
to get to zero, it just
has to get to a small value
where it matches to the
decaying exponential.
So if the curvature is less,
then the energy is less.
Cool?
OK, next question.
So any questions
on that before I?
Good.
Time zero wave function
infinite well with a
is this, sine squared
with a normalization.
What's the wave function
at a subsequent time t?
I will remind you
that you have solved
the problem of the
infinite square well,
and you know what
the eigenenergies
and eigenfunctions
are of the energy
operator in the
infinite square well.
So remember back
to what those are.
All right, and you
have five seconds.
OK, we are at about
50-50 correct.
So chat with the
person next to you.
All right.
And now, any moment, go
ahead and vote again.
Good, five more seconds and
then put in your final vote.
OK, that's it for now.
So what's the answer?
D is the answer, but a lot of
people still had some doubts.
So who wants to give an
explanation for why it's D?
AUDIENCE: So sine squared
is not an eigenfunction.
PROFESSOR: Fantastic.
AUDIENCE: So in some
way it hast to be
a summation of eigenfunctions.
So not even having to know
what the eigenfunctions are,
there's only one
summation in it.
PROFESSOR: Excellent, excellent.
AUDIENCE: And if you do know
what the eigenfunctions are,
now you know that [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Brilliant, so
I'm going to restate that.
That was exactly
correct in every step.
So the first thing is, that
wave function at time 0,
sine squared of x, is not an
eigenfunction of the energy
operator for the system.
In fact, we've computed the
eigenfunctions for the energy
operator in the
infinite square well,
and they're sines where
they get a zero at the ends.
On the other hand, any function
satisfying the boundary
conditions-- normalizable,
hits zero at the boundaries--
is a superposition of
energy eigenfunctions,
and we can use that to determine
the time evolution we take
that superposition
and add on a phase-- e
to the minus i et upon h
bar for each of the energy
eigenfunctions.
And in part D we
express that wave
function as a superposition with
the coefficient cn determined
from the overlap of our
original function and the energy
eigenfunctions.
Everyone cool with that?
So this is literally just
a transcription of one
of our postulates.
OK, questions?
If you have any questions
at all, ask them.
This is the time to ask them.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the way
get cn [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So the way you get
cn is by saying,
look I have my
wave function, psi
of x is equal to sum
over n cn phi n of z,
where these phi n's
energy eigenfunctions.
E phi n is equal
to en phi m of x.
And we also know that
the integral of phi n's
complex conjugate phi
m is equal to delta mn.
This is the statement
that they're
orthogonal and
properly normalized.
We also write this as
equal to phi n phi m.
And we can use this
to determine the cn is
equal to the inner product of
phi m with our wave function.
This is equal to the integral
dx phi star phi n star
psi, which is equal to
the integral dx phi n star
sum over m of cm phi m.
But this sum over m of
cm can be pulled out
because this is just an integral
over a sum of terms, which
is the same as the sum
over m cm integral phi
m-- complex conjugate-- phi m.
And that's delta mn, which
is 0 unless n is equal to m,
because these guys are
orthogonal and properly
normalized.
So this is zero unless
n is equal to m.
So in the sum, the only
term that contributes
is when m is equal to
n, this is equal to cn.
So cn is given by the
overlap of our wave function
with the corresponding
eigenfunction.
This allows us to take our
function, a known function--
for example, sine squared--
and express the coefficients
in terms of an overlap of our
wave function sine squared
with the wave functions sine.
And that's exactly the
expression you see below,
cn is equal to the
integral of sine
squared-- our wave
function-- times
sine, which is the
energy eigenfunction.
Other questions?
OK, great.
Next problem.
Come to me computer.
Why can they just be
written in Python.
OK, good.
the eigenstates phi n--
which we usually call psi n,
but there it is-- form
an orthonormal set.
Meaning integral of phi
m star phi n is delta mn.
What is the value of integral
psi m against the sum cn phi n?
You've got five seconds.
I'll give you a
little extra time,
because people
are clicking away.
OK you now have seven seconds,
because time is non-linear.
OK, so quickly discuss,
because there's still
some ambiguity here.
All right, you have 10
seconds to modify your clicks.
Click.
All right, yes and the
answer is, C, excellent.
Right?
Because in fact,
we just did that.
That won't happen
on the actual exam.
So here's the next question.
Let the Hamiltonian
on a dagger Un
equal en plus h
omega-- that should
be an h bar-- a dagger Un.
What can you say
about a dagger Un?
Here we should
probably say, what
can one say, because
it's possible-- OK,
what can one say?
Here the assumption--
just to say it out
loud-- the assumption is
that Un is an eigenfunction
of the energy operator
h with eigenvalue en.
You've got five seconds.
All right, we are at 50/50.
So discuss amongst yourselves.
All right.
OK, go ahead and enter again.
Enter your modified guesses.
And you have 10
seconds to do so.
This is a lot better.
OK, this is great.
So this is one of those
really satisfying moments.
It's improved, but there's
still some real doubt here.
So I would like to get
one person to argue
for b and one person
to argue for c.
So who wants to volunteer
for each of those?
AUDIENCE: I'll argue for c.
PROFESSOR: Who's
going to argue for b?
Someone's got to
argue for b, come on.
AUDIENCE: You can argue.
PROFESSOR: I'm not
going to argue for b.
I'm not going to
argue for c either.
That defeats the purpose.
I'm the professor.
I have to say this all the time.
So who's going to argue for b?
OK, you argue for b.
Who's going to argue for c?
All right, yeah,
that worked out well.
Great.
Argue for b.
You can do it.
AUDIENCE: So I originally
accidentally mis-clicked b,
so I guess I can do this.
So originally I didn't
read the question,
and I thought since you
were acting the letter
operator on the
eigenstate that you'd
get a proportionality constant
times some eigenstate.
So that's why it could
potentially be b.
But I disbelieve.
PROFESSOR: It's not the best
argument imaginable for b,
but we'll take it.
So thank you.
When I put someone in
an impossible position.
So c.
AUDIENCE: All right.
I argue for c.
So we can see just
from the first line
here that this is clearly going
to be a stationary [INAUDIBLE].
However, we can also see that
it is a distinctly different
energy from the
state that you get
an eigenfunction [INAUDIBLE].
So I said c, because it
was not the same state.
PROFESSOR: Fantastic.
That's exactly right.
So let me walk through that.
Let me say that allowed.
So from the first line, it
is clear that the object a Un
is an eigenfunction of
the energy operator.
And it's got eigenvalue
en plus h omega.
So it is a stationary state.
It's an eigenfunction of
the energy [INAUDIBLE].
However, it is not the
same one, because it
has a different eigenvalue.
So what it means to be
the same energy eigenstate
is it has the same eigenvalue.
If it has a different
energy eigenvalue,
it is a different state
and they're orthogonal.
We proved this before.
Two states with different
energy are orthogonal.
So not only are
they not the same,
they don't even
have any overlap.
So it is a stationary
state, but it's not
proportional with the state Un.
It's an important one.
Questions about that one
before we move on to the next?
AUDIENCE: How did
you tell that it's
proportional to the state Un?
PROFESSOR: If it were
proportional to the state Un,
then it would be some
constant times Un.
That's what we mean by
saying it's proportional.
But then if we acted on it
with the energy operator,
what would the eigenvalue be?
Let me say this again.
Suppose I have a
state the Un, which
I know that if I act with
the energy operator on it--
or this is sometimes called
h Un is equal to En Un.
If I act with E on alpha Un,
where alpha's a constant,
what is this equal to?
Alpha EnUn.
So the eigenvalue is the same.
It's En, because it can
divide through by [INAUDIBLE].
So if you have the same state--
meaning proportional to it--
then we'll have the
same eigenvalue.
But this manifestly has
a different eigenvalue.
Cool?
Awesome, OK other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I must have missed
the-- this is [INAUDIBLE].
What is the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah, good.
So H is another name.
So some books use H
and some books use E.
And the reason goes back
to classical mechanics.
There's an object called
the Hamiltonian, which
is sort of like
saying-- I don't know.
It's like saying bread
and [NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
are the same thing.
But they evoke different things.
You say bread and
you think like Dixie.
And you say
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH] and you
think, the me of some
gorgeous baguette.
It has a different feel.
So this evokes different things.
In particular, to a
classical mechanic
the Hamiltonian is the
generator of time translations.
Now, we don't
usually-- that wasn't
the classic way of thinking
about the energy operator
in, say, Newton's time.
But it is how we think
about energy now.
So that's just terminology.
For anyone who didn't get
that, sorry about that.
This is something that
we've run across before,
but I should emphasize.
So when you hear people
say the Hamiltonian,
that means the energy operator.
The reason I say
energy operator rather
than saying
Hamiltonian-- which is
the more common thing in
the Lingua Franca of quantum
mechanics-- is because I
want to impress upon you guys
that it's just energy.
It is the energy,
it's nothing else.
It's not some strange beast.
It's just energy.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Which one's the bread?
PROFESSOR: Bread.
Other questions?
Next question.
Which of these graphs shows the
curvature of the wave function
in a classically allowed region?
OK, five seconds left.
All right, fantastic.
And the answer is a,
because the curvature
has to be towards the axis.
In the classically
allowed region,
the wave function is sinusoidal.
it's oscillatory.
All right, and-- whoops.
And the partner of
that question is,
what about in the classically
disallowed region?
Five seconds.
OK, awesome, and basically
everyone got this.
B, great.
Questions?
Yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No.
No, that's a very good question.
So C and D, let me be a little
bit more precise about it.
It's a very reasonable question,
so let me give you an answer.
Suppose you saw a
wave function that
had the curvature
structure of C.
It was curved
oscillatory over there
and curved exponential
over there on the right.
What would you say about
the potential relative
to the energy?
Say again?
Yeah, good.
So on one side we're allowed,
and on the other side
we're disallowed.
So if you saw a
wave function that
had that curvature
structure, you'd
immediately know that it was
an allowed region on the left.
But then on the right, it
was classically disallowed,
because it had curvature
away from the axis.
That cool?
So if you saw a wave
function-- so for example, you
might say look, you never get
a wave function that does this.
And that's not true.
You could do that.
So this would be
classically disallowed,
because it's curvature down.
This would be
classically allowed.
So the potential, for example,
if this is the energy,
the potential could be.
So a potential like this could
lead to a function like this.
So it's a very good question.
I'm sorry, I should
have seen what
you were asking
more immediately.
Other questions
following up on that?
No one ever asked
that question before.
And I just want to emphasize
that you guys should just ask
questions when you don't--
when you've confused about
something, someone else is
going to be confused about it.
I wouldn't even necessarily
know that the question
is a meaningful question.
I get questions I've
never heard before all
the time in this class.
Just don't hesitate to ask.
It's always a good idea.
OK, next one.
Wave function psi
has been expressed
as a sum over energy
eigenfunction Un.
Compared to the
original wave function,
is a function of x a
set of coefficients,
C1 dot dot dot contains more
or less, same information?
Or it can't be determined?
Or depends?
Five seconds.
And the answer is.
AUDIENCE: C.
PROFESSOR: Same information.
Good questions.
Some of these
you've seen before.
f and g are wave functions
and c is a constant.
Then the inner product
cf with g is equal to?
Click away, 10 seconds.
All right.
OK, you've got
about five seconds.
Still a lot of
fluctuations here.
Wow, I'm surprised by this one.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, quick
question on the previous one.
PROFESSOR: Oh, let's come
back to the previous one
after we do this one.
Thanks.
But remind me too
after we move on.
So discuss, because about 1/3
of you got this one wrong.
So discuss.
So go ahead and put
in your answers again.
Good.
All right, another five seconds.
OK, and the answer is.
Good, get that complex
conjugation right.
Little things like
that can cause
you an infinite
amount of trouble.
Especially as you'll notice
on the problem set when you're
computing time dependence
of expectation values,
getting that complex
conjugation right
is essential, because you need
to see interference terms.
And without the
complex conjugation
you will not get the
right interference terms.
Oh yeah, a question from
the previous problem.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So since the
summation with the constants,
doesn't that
technically give you
the probability of each
individual eigenstate?
PROFESSOR: The norm squared
gives you the probabilities.
But if you know
the coefficients---
so this is a good question.
So let me rephrase the question.
The question is, in the
previous question we said,
our wave function phi of
x is some function which
we could draw.
So I could represent
this in two ways.
I could either draw it,
or I could represent
it as equal the sum
over n of cn phi
n where phi n are the
known energy functions.
And the question is, did the cn
contain the same information?
So that was the question.
And the point that's
being asked about here
is a very good question.
The question is, look, we
know what these cn's mean.
What the cn's mean
is the probability
that you measure
the energy-- given
that the state of psi, the
probability [INAUDIBLE] energy
En is equal to norm cn squared.
And so the cn's tell
you about probabilities.
They don't tell you
what the state is.
They just tell you
what a probability
is that you'll measure
a particular energy.
Is that right?
So how can it contain
the same information?
And there are two important
things to say about this.
First off, this
is of course true.
And this does give
you the probability.
And the probability comes
from the norm squared.
So the phase of cn doesn't
particularly matter for that.
However the claim that I
can expand this function
in a basis of the
energy eigenfunctions,
in a basis of other
functions, is a statement
that if know these cn's, then
I take c1 multiplied by phi 1,
c2 multiplied by phi 2,
add them all back up,
and I get nothing other
than this original function.
So if I know the
cn's, I can just
construct that original
function explicitly.
So this can't contain
any more or any less
information than the
list of cn's, as long
as I know what basis
I'm talking about.
So here's the disturbing
thing about that.
When we say the wave function
is the state of the system--
it contains all knowledge you
could possibly have access to.
And not just knowledge that
you could have access to,
it contains all of the
information of the state.
And then we look at
this and say, well look,
it doesn't give us
something deterministic.
It gives us something
probabilistic.
It tells us the
probability distribution
for measuring the various
different energies.
What does that
immediately tell you
since they're
equivalent information?
This guy tells you nothing
more than the probabilities.
It doesn't tell you what
energies you'll measure,
it tells you the
probabilities with which
you will measure energies.
So they're the same thing.
It's a very good question.
And I think the way to take
the sort of discomfort--
I don't know about
you-- but that
causes me is just to read
that as saying, look,
the wave function is giving
you probabilistic information
about measurements.
AUDIENCE: I get that.
It's just that if you have
a wave function written
as that or a wave function
written as the [INAUDIBLE],
I just see-- since
it's written that way,
then you know what
all the cn's are
and what all the
possible eigenstates are.
And just [INAUDIBLE].
I understand they both
contain the same information,
but just written as each.
PROFESSOR: Excellent, excellent.
So let me turn this around.
Let me phrase this
slightly different.
Tell me if this is
getting at the same point.
If I gave you a list
of numbers, 1, 14, 12,
does that tell you what
function I'm talking about?
No.
I have to tell you that they're
the expansion coefficients
in, say, sine waves of
a particular wavelength.
Or energy eigenfunctions of
some particular energy operator.
If I just give you
a list of numbers,
it doesn't tell you
what function it is.
I have to give you
a list of numbers,
and I have to tell you what
basis I'm talking about.
If you have the
wave function, you
don't need to know what
basis you're talking about.
The wave function is
basis independent.
It's just the function.
In a few minutes, I'm going
to come back and subvert
what I just said.
So the wave function is just
what the wave function is.
And if I give you
a list of numbers,
they're only equivalent when
you also know the wave function.
So in order for these two
things to be equivalent,
it's important that you know
what bases are talking about.
In particular, it's
important that you
know the energy eigenfunctions.
Is that getting at the
distinction you're making?
OK, think more about it.
And when the question
becomes more sharp, ask.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I think you kind of
covered what my question was.
But for the future, if the
question is phrased such
that if you know the cn's,
you know all the information,
are we supposed to just
infer that if we know the cn,
we also know [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, usually.
I try on problem sets in exams
to make that distinction clear,
but that will
generally be assumed.
Other questions?
I'm going to come back to this.
I'm going to come
back to this when
we finish the clicker questions.
Next question.
In the simple
harmonic oscillator,
the eigenvalues-- as
we've described twice--
our En is h bar omega times
n plus 1/2 for an integer n,
and a measurement of
energy will always
observe one of these values.
That's from postulate four.
Three?
What can we say about
the expectation value
of the energy in
some arbitrary state?
This one isn't tricky,
but it's not trivial.
So think carefully about it.
You have five seconds.
Enter your best guess.
And you are at complete chance.
I think we've just put you
through a hardness box.
So discuss.
OK go ahead and start putting
in your modified response.
You have another
five seconds or so.
OK, click.
OK, there's still a lot
of disagreement here.
So let's see.
So who would like
to argue for C?
Who would like to argue for D?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: OK, so I'm
going to argue for D.
And against C. So C suggests
that we would measure
the value of the [INAUDIBLE]
only for eigenstate that it
addressed.
But even if that changed,
the stationary state
consists of one
and one eigenstate.
So if we were to
find the value, it
can still be a combination
of 1 and [INAUDIBLE].
And it doesn't have to fall
to a certain eigenvalue.
PROFESSOR: Excellent, excellent.
So let me restate that.
So the statement-- if
I'm following your logic.
Thank you.
So at the statement if
I'm following your logic
goes something like this.
Look, if we had the
wave function which
was phi sub n times some
phase, some ridiculous phase.
Let's say the phase was 1.
If we had the wave
function as phi sub n,
what will the expectation
value of the energy operator
be in this state?
En, right?
Because it's the energy.
It's a sum of all possible n
of En times the probability
that we measure
En, by definition,
but this is equal to
sum over n of En times
the expansion coefficient of
our wave function in the energy
eigenstate basis cn squared.
Now, what's the
expansion coefficient
in our energy eigenbasis here?
It's 1 for a particular value
of n, and 0 for everything else.
So what will our answer be?
It will be 0 for
everything except 1
for a particular value En
corresponding to little m.
I should really call this m, so
that dummy variables that we're
summing over don't matter.
So for this particular case
the expectation value of e
is equal to En.
Everyone cool with that?
So it certainly can be En.
But is this the
only way to get En?
No.
So for example, suppose we have
alpha phi 1 plus beta phi 3.
What will the answer be?
Now first off, in order
to make this normalizable,
what does beta have to be?
It needs to be square of 1
minus alpha norm squared.
Just so that they sum
to 1 when norm squared.
So what I want to plot
now the expectation
value of the energy as
a function of alpha.
When alpha is 0, what
is the expectation value
of the energy?
E3.
When alpha is 1-- which it can't
be anything greater than 1--
when alpha is 1, what
is the expectation value
of the energy?
E1.
And how does the expectation
value of the energy
vary between these two
as a function of alpha?
Well, it's smooth.
In particular, it's
quadratic because it
goes like the square
of these coefficients.
So it's something smooth
that does this and has
slope 0 at the end.
And somewhere in
between, it will hit E2.
But not only is this
not equal to E2,
it doesn't even contain E2 as
an element of the superposition.
So this is a counter-example to
C. This is an important point.
Now if I know that at
some moment in time,
the energy expectation
value is this value,
corresponding let's say
to some particular alpha,
and I let the system
evolve in time,
how does that expectation
value evolve in time?
How does the expectation value
of the energy change over time?
It doesn't.
The expectation value of energy
is always time independent.
Does the expectation value
of position change over time?
In general, yes.
When does it not
change over time?
In a stationary state.
So working through
this is what's
on your previous
problem set, as well
as on your current problem set.
AUDIENCE: So is this
anything like conservation
of energy, where the
expectation value of energy
needs to stay the same if
there's nothing going on?
PROFESSOR: Excellent, it
sort of sounds like that.
We'll make a sharp
version of that later.
So you should have that tinkling
in the back of your head
as like, oh look, we have a
time independent potential,
energy is conserved.
That sounds kind of like the
expectation value is constant.
But we need to make
that more precise.
So we'll find a precise
version of that statement later
in the semester.
But it's a very good
intuition to have.
Other questions?
OK, so the answer is D.
And you guys were about 4/5
on that at the end.
Oops, that was not right.
OK, next one.
This is a three-step question.
We have observable A and B with
eigenstates psi 1 and psi 2,
and phi 1 and phi 2 of
A and B, and eigenvalues
of a1, a2, and b1, b2.
And the eigenstate's related
in this linear fashion.
I measure observable A
and get the value of a1.
What's the state immediately
after that measurement?
What is the wave function?
Five seconds.
2-1.
Click away.
So there's pretty strong
agreement among you all
that the answer is A, and
that is indeed the answer.
Questions?
So a slightly less obvious one.
Immediately after
this measurement of A,
observable B is measured.
What's the probability
the b1 is found?
Wow, there's some amazing
initial transience there.
I could use the first
couple of seconds
as a random number generator.
OK, that's it.
And there's actually
a third of you
disagree with the
correct answer.
So I'm going to invite you
to chat with each other.
Go ahead and update
your answers.
OK, five more seconds.
One second.
OK, nice.
Excellent.
You guys went from about 65%
to 90%, so that was great.
The answer is E.
It's the norm squared
of the coefficient of
eigenfunction corresponding
to b1 in the original
state, which was psi 1.
Now imagine, on the other hand,
that the grad student doing
the measurement failed
to in fact measure
the observable B-- it was a bad
day-- but instead measured A
again.
What's the probability
that the second measurement
will yield a1?
Trust me on this one,
there's so many ways.
They read the package wrong,
they did the wrong measurement.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry, thank
you, thank you, thank you.
Very good question.
He accidentally
measured B instead of A.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I mean A instead
of B. A instead of B. See
how easy it is to
make that mistake?
He accidentally
measured A instead of B.
I wish that was intentional.
OK, and so and we got
almost total unanimity.
The answer is B. Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: I was just going
to ask how quickly after.
PROFESSOR: Great question.
Let's just assume
it's instantaneous.
Maybe sloppy, but
he's very quick.
OK, next question.
A system is in a state which
is a linear superposition of n
equals 1 and n equals 2
energy eigenstates, blah.
What's the probability that
measurement of the energy
will yield the first
energy eigenvalue?
Another five seconds, 2-3-4-5.
Great, you guys totally agree
that the answer is C. Great.
That's it for the clicker
questions for today.
So here's the thing
I want to emphasize.
The first is that these
were totally conceptual.
They did not involve
any computations.
And yet, they're not trivial.
Some of them got 50%
consistently across the class.
So it's not just the
calculations that are hard.
Just thinking through the basic
premises, the basic postulates,
is really essential
at this point.
It's more important
than the computation.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are you
going to post this?
PROFESSOR: I will post these.
I will post these.
Any questions remaining
after this-- oh, shoot!
I missed out on a
whole opportunity.
I'll do it next time.
Poo.
Any other questions before
we move on to lecture part?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, you
totally have to wait.
Yeah, you totally have to wait.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever have
a [INAUDIBLE] function
that's odd?
Or just continues
down [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
a very good question.
So the question is,
can you ever have
a potential function
that is odd?
So for example-- you're
actually asking two questions,
so let me disentangle them.
So one question is, can I
have an a potential function
which is odd and linear?
So it just ramps
all the way down.
So does that seem physical?
Is the energy
bounded from below?
Well, that's a not a
terribly good criterion
because it's not bounded
from below for the Coulomb
potential either.
But in the case of
the Coulomb potential,
it's not bounded from below
in a little tiny region.
Not in a huge swath.
So we're going to need a
better definition than this,
but the short answer
to this one is no.
This is not good.
On the other hand, it's
not the oddness that's bad.
It's that the
energy is continuing
to be unbounded from below.
So let me be more precise
than saying it's not happy.
What important
for an observable?
What's important
for the operator
corresponding to an observable
in quantum mechanics?
What property must
that operator have?
It has to be Hermitian.
And [INAUDIBLE] that
implies real eigenvalues.
It implies that there's a basis
of its eigenfunctions, all
these nice things.
What we will find is that
the Coulomb potential--
the hydrogen potential-- gives
us a nice Hermitian energy
operator.
We'll prove that
the energy operator
self-adjoint on a problem set.
However, this guy will not.
So we're going to have one
that is not bounded from below.
And so while there's a sense
in which it's Hermitian,
there's not a good sense.
It's got problems.
But that's a more
technical detail.
However, there's a second
part of your question, which
is you could have
been asking, look,
can you have a
potential that's odd
but let's leave aside the
diverging at infinity.
So for example, could
you have a potential
that does this so that
it's odd, but it's bounded?
And that's fine.
Nothing wrong with that.
So odd isn't a problem.
The problem is certain
ways of diverging.
AUDIENCE: So what would
happen in the case
where you did have some
kind of linear potential?
You had a uniform electric
field and something was moving.
Is the problem that that
potential technically
isn't a physical potential
because it doesn't go away?
PROFESSOR: How would you ever
build a linear potential,
right?
So the question here
is, look, I know
how to build a linear potential.
Turn a uniform electric
field, and an electric field
is the gradient to the
electrostatic potential.
So that means that the
electrostatic potential
is linear.
And the potential energy
of a charged particle
with charge Q in an
electrostatic potential
is q times the
electrostatic potential.
So the potential energy
for that charged particle
is a linear function.
So how do I build such a thing?
Well, I take two
capacitor plates,
and I dump some
charge on this one,
and the opposite
charge on this guy,
and I build up a
linear potential.
Well yeah, exactly.
So that's the problem.
So can I make this linear over
an arbitrarily large domain?
No.
I need an arbitrarily
large amount of charge,
and I need to push them apart
from each other arbitrarily
far, which takes an arbitrarily
large amount of work.
That's not terribly
physical, right?
Your arms are only so big.
So at the end and
the day, we're always
going to discover that the
pathologies that show up
in a potential like this,
like the Hamiltonian's not
self-adjoint and
compactly supported
[INAUDIBLE] continuous
functions, then OK.
That's going to always be
some mathematical version of,
your arms are only so big.
You cannot build an infinitely
large apparatus like this.
So yes, you're exactly right.
It is not physical.
Is it a mathematical
problem one could analyze?
Yes.
One could write a dissertation
on the singularity structure
of these differential equations.
But that dissertation would
never be read by a physicist.
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Talking about the
rising and lowering number.
Can you find the raising and
lowering for any [INAUDIBLE]
potential.
PROFESSOR: Excellent question.
No.
So here's what you can do.
Suppose I have a bunch
of energy eigenstates.
I have some potential.
This is the potential.
It's a crazy potential.
And it has some definite
energy eigenvalues.
As we've shown in 1D, or as
I've mentioned and proved
in office hours, we can't
find degenerate eigenfunctions
in a one-dimensional potential.
So they're not degenerate.
They're spaced a
finite distance apart
for wave functions that
are convergent to 0
and infinity for bound states.
So we can always
construct an operator,
which I will simply
define in this way.
A, and just for flourish
I will put a dagger on it
which does the following.
A dagger is the
defined as the operator
that maps phi n to
phi m, n plus 1.
So what's the rule?
It takes this state
to this state,
this state to this state,
this state to this state.
And since we can extend--
since these are a basis,
then that tells us how this
acts on an arbitrary function,
because it acts on the
superposition as acting
on each term.
So we can define it in this
way, but here's the question.
What does it mean for
the raising operator
to be the raising operator?
It wasn't that it lifted
to raise the operator.
That's not what started
out the whole machinery.
Where the raising
operator got its juice was
from this computational
relation, a dagger with E
was equal to h bar
omega a dagger.
So can we build an
operator a dagger
that raises states and
commutes with the energy
operator in this fashion?
No, that depends on
the energy operator.
This is not a general property.
This is not always
something we can do.
If we could, then
that energy operator
would have evenly spaced
energy eigenfunctions.
On the other hand, it's
not like it's never useful.
So consider the
following example.
And I think this was
on your problem set
but I don't remember.
So let me just say it.
If we write a dagger
a is equal to n,
then the commutation relation
for this-- so the energy
operator for the
harmonic oscillator
was equal to h bar
omega n plus 1/2.
That's what we
derived last time.
If we define a dagger a
as n, then the commutator
of n with a dagger is a dagger.
And the commutator of n
with a is equal to minus a.
Suppose the energy
operator is equal to h
bar omega n plus n cubed.
Does the raising operator
commute with the energy
operator to give
you a dagger again?
No, because it commutes to give
you an a dagger and it commutes
with this guy to give you,
well, a constant times n
squared a dagger, which is a
slightly funny [INAUDIBLE].
So this doesn't have the
same computational relations.
On the other hand, we know how
to build the functions of the n
operator because they live
in a tower by this algebra.
By this commutator relation,
they live in a tower.
So I can build the
eigenfunctions of n.
And then I can take those
eigenfunctions of n and act
on them with e and
discover that they're also
eigenfunctions of e.
Because e acting on them
is just n, and n cubed
acting on the
eigenfunctions of n.
So the states with
definite n are still
eigenfunctions of
the energy operator.
But they're not evenly spaced.
Now can every
potential be written
in terms of this n operator.
So I leave that
you as an exercise.
The answer is no.
Try it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So there's always something
you could formally
define in this fashion.
It's not always useful to
you, because it doesn't always
commute with the energy
operator in a nice way.
So then you can ask,
are there properties
that aren't nice about this?
Well, there's something called
the supersymmetric method
in 1D quantum mechanics.
But that's sort of
beyond the scope.
Come to my office hours and
ask me this question again.
This is a miracle of
the harmonic oscillator.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So to
construct the [INAUDIBLE]
we use a condition
that a phi 0 is 0?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how did
we come up with that?
Did we demand that on physical
grounds that it had to be 0?
PROFESSOR: Yes, we did.
So excellent question.
So the question is this.
When we constructed
using the operator method
for the harmonic oscillator,
when we constructed the ground
state, we said the
ground state, phi 0,
is that state which is
annihilated by the learning
operator.
A phi 0 is equal to 0.
So where did that come from?
Were we forcing that
for physical reasons?
For mathematical reasons?
What was the reason?
So this was very important,
so let's go through it slowly.
So remember the step that came
immediately before this step.
Immediately before
this step we said,
look the expectation
value of energy
can always be written as
a strictly positive thing.
It's equal to the
integral and you
should derive this for yourself.
I didn't derive it, but
this is a good thing
to derive for yourself.
It takes only a couple of steps.
Integral overall
momentum of psi tilde
of p-- the Fourier
transformer norm squared.
This is the probability that
you have given the state psi.
This is the probability
density that you
have momentum p, p
squared upon 2 m.
Plus the integral
dx psi of x norm
squared m omega squared
upon 2 x squared.
This is the probability
that you're at position
x, given the wave function x.
And that's the value
of the potential.
Now this is a strictly
positive quantity, as is this.
Strictly positive, as is this.
This is a plus.
This quantity must always be
greater than or equal to 0.
Correct?
However, we derive from
the operator relations
that if we take away
function phi sub e
and we act on it with
the lowering operator a,
this defines a new state,
which up to some normalization
is an eigenfunction of the
energy operator with energy
e minus h bar omega.
And we show this by showing that
the energy eigenfunction acting
on this gives exactly this
coefficient times this back.
It's an eigenfunction.
We just showed explicitly
that it's an eigenfunction.
So this suggest that if you
have a state with energy e,
you could also build a state
with energy e minus h bar
omega.
And thus we can repeat
e minus 2 h bar omega,
and this turtles
all the way down.
The problem is, for
any finite value of e,
eventually this tower
will get negative.
Here's 0.
But the energy expectation
value cannot be less than 0.
It's got to be strictly
greater than 0.
But if we were in
this energy eigenstate
and we measured the
expectation value of energy,
this is the value we would
get, which would be negative.
Whoops, that's a 2.
So something is amiss.
How can this
possibly make sense?
And the answer up
with was, well look,
it's inescapable that
acting with A n phi
gives us something that's an
eigenfunction of the energy.
However, it's possible
that this function
happens to be the 0 function.
Not 0 energy, just
0, not a function.
Is zero normalizable?
No, the integral
of 0 squared is 0.
No coefficient times that
is a finite number, is 1.
So what must happen is it must
be true that at some point
we can't lower anymore.
But we don't always act with
a, so we always try to lower.
The only out is if when we
lower one particular guy, which
I will call phi 0, the only out
is if we try to lower phi 0,
we don't get another state--
which we see we did here.
We don't get another state.
Instead, we just get 0.
We get no state.
Not energy 0.
0, the function is 0,
identically vanishing.
This does not describe the
configuration of [INAUDIBLE].
The probability of it
being anywhere is 0.
That's bad.
So in order for
the tower to end,
in order for the energy
to be bounded from below
as the potential is,
we need that there's
a lowest state in the tower.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Are the energy
eigenfunctions always strictly
real?
PROFESSOR: Very good question.
You're going to show
this on a problem set
if you haven't already.
I thought you did,
but maybe not.
The energy eigenfunctions
for potentials
with only bound
states can always
be expressed as purely
real or purely imaginary.
You can always
decompose them in terms
of purely real and
purely imaginary.
Proving that will be a problem
on one of your problem sets.
But for the moment, let me
just say, yes, you can always
show that the energy
eigenfunctions
for 1 D potential can always
be expressed as purely real.
I need that bound
state condition,
as we'll see later
in the course.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So we lowered
the energy [INAUDIBLE].
And the next energy is 0, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that supposed
to mean that the [INAUDIBLE] is
h omega, not h omega over 2?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
No, good.
So what this says is given
some state with energy e,
when we lower it we
get h bar omega less.
That doesn't tell you what e is.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Just to
expand on that.
So if you get the 0 function,
that doesn't actually
correspond to any energy
eigenvalue, let alone 0, right?
PROFESSOR: Correct.
The function 0 is
an eigenfunction
of every operator.
But it's a stupid eigenfunction
In particuar, it
has nothing to do
with the states
we're interested in.
We are interested in
normalizable states,
and that is not a
normalizable state.
You can't multiply it by
any finite coefficient
and get 1 when you
square integrate it.
One last question.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a
stupid question.
But does that mean that the only
particle that can have 0 energy
is the particle
that doesn't exist?
PROFESSOR: Well, we need
to add more work to that.
So the question
is, does that mean
that the only particle that
could really have 0 energy
is some imaginary particle
that doesn't exist.
First off, imaginary
particles may exist.
We just haven't seen them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] real
particle [INAUDIBLE] 0 energy.
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, so I need to say
two things about this.
So there's a
technical complaint I
need to make about
your question, which
is a very fair question.
But I need to make
it all the same.
And the second is a
more physical answer.
So the technical complaint is,
what do you mean by 0 energy?
Do you ever measure
energy directly?
You measure energy differences.
So relative to what?
We have to decide,
relative to what?
So for example, in the
harmonic oscillator
what we mean when we say
the [INAUDIBLE] energy is
non-zero is if we
draw the potential,
and we call the minimum
of the potential e is 0,
classical e is 0,
then what we discover
is that the energy of the
quantum mechanical ground state
is 1/2 h bar omega above 0.
So is there any state of
the harmonic oscillator
with energy 0?
No.
If we have a free
particle, is there
a configuration with energy 0?
Well, that's an
interesting question.
So what are the
eigenstates, e to the ikx.
When the energy is 0-- so the
energy is-- because it's just
p squared upon 2m, which is h
bar squared k squared upon 2m,
the energy is h bar
squared k squared up
on 2m for a free
particle, no potential.
And by 0 we mean the
asymptotic energy equals 0.
Can you have a
state with energy 0?
This one's a little subtle,
because if we take the energy
0, what must k be?
0, OK great.
So what's the wave function?
Constant.
Is that normalizable?
Not so much.
So can you put a single particle
in a state with energy 0?
No, that would not
seem to be possible,
because that would be a
non-normalzable state.
Well you say, we deal with
these exponentials all the time.
We know how to deal with that.
We don't use a
single wave-- plane
wave-- we use a wave
packet with some width.
So I can build a wave packet
with some average width,
but will that average width ever
have an expectation value of k
equals 0?
No, because it will always have
contributions from k not equal
0 so that it's
specially localized.
So can you build a
normalizable state
with energy 0, which is an
eigenfunction of the energy 0?
No, not in this case either.
So there's the
technical complaint
that you need to talk about
what you mean relative to what.
That was about your question.
And the second of, can you
ever have an energy eigenstate
which is at the minimum
of the potential?
And that's also 0.
That's also no.
You'll actually prove that
on a later problem set.
So with all that
said, we have a mere--
that's awesome-- 15 minutes
for a 14-page lecture.
So can I do this fast?
No, I'm kidding.
I won't do that to you.
So I want to just-- instead
of going through it.
So this was not directly
relevant for the exam.
And this can come
a little bit later.
So let me show you a
couple of quick things.
So the notes are posted online.
Look at them.
I'll go over them
again in the future.
What do I want to do?
So I want to introduce
to you two ideas.
One is Dirac notation.
And this is hearkening back
to basics of vector spaces.
And the second is,
I want to tell you
something about what
the commutator means.
So first off, let me
ask you guys a question.
I have one more clicker
question for you.
All right, are you all ready?
Everyone up with the clickers?
Here's is the question.
[MUSIC PLAYING - JEOPARDY THEME]
OK, go ahead and
start clicking now.
Sigma's the uncertainty.
Sorry, sigma is the uncertainty.
This is awesome.
I swear the clicks are going
in beat with the music.
So let me give you
three more seconds.
1-2-3.
This is awesome.
You guys are totally at chance.
You have even probability
distribution across the three.
So this is good, because
we haven't actually
introduced this idea yet in 804.
So let me quickly
talk you through this.
So I'll leave it off.
So let me quickly
talk you through this.
And this is important.
This is going to give you some
intuition for what uncertainty
means.
And it's also going to give
you some intuition for what
the commutator means.
So this is a little more
experience, a little more
practice with operators.
And we'll pick up on the
Dirac notation and everything
next time.
Because I just want to
get through this physics.
So consider two operators,
A and B. So A and B
are my two operators.
They have hats.
He has a top hot.
So we have-- you've got to
make this stuff a little more
light hearted.
So we have two operators,
A and B. And I want to ask,
is it possible for there to be
a function phi little a little
b which is simultaneously
an eigenfunction of a
and an eigenfunction of b?
So now this is a
pure math question.
Given two operators,
a and b, can you
build a function which
is simultaneously
an eigenfunction of a and
an eigenfunction of b?
I will call this phi sub ab.
Why not?
OK, phi sub ab
has this property.
And phi ab is equal to little a.
Why not?
And b on phi ab is equal
to little b on phi ab.
You can't stop me, I have
now created this object.
From the existence
of this state,
what can you deduce about
the operators a and b?
And if you've already seen
this before, that's cheating.
So don't raise your hand.
But if you haven't seen it
before, just think through it.
What does this tell you
about the operators a and b?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Great.
That's a nice guess.
I like that guess.
So let's check.
So what would it mean for the
commutator of a and b to be 0?
So this is equal to ab minus ba.
And what the commutator does
is it takes two operators
and it gives you a new
operator called bracket ab.
And sometimes it's useful to
call it c, for commutator.
So it gives you a new operator.
Given two operators you
build a new operator.
And suppose now that we
have a common eigenfunction
of a and b.
What does that tell you?
Well, let's take the
commutator-- a, b--
and let's take it and
act on phi of sub ab
on this common eigenstate.
So what is this equal to?
This is equal to ab
minus ba phi b, which
I can write as ab phi
ab minus ba phi ab
by linearity-- by
addition, really.
But b acting on phi ab gives
me, by hypothesis, little b.
And then a acting on a
constant times phi ab
gives me a little a times
that constant minus-- now
here a acting on phi ab
gives me little a phi ab.
And then b acting on constant
times phi ab gives me little b.
And now I can join
these together.
This is equal to little
ab minus ba phi ab.
But little a and
little b are numbers.
If you take 7 times 5 and 5
times 7 and you subtract them,
what do you get?
0.
So in order for a and b to share
a single eigenfunction phi ab,
what must be true
of their commutator?
It must have an a
non-zero kernel, exactly.
The commutator must annihilate
that particular common
eigenfunction.
Does it tell you that
it kills every function?
No.
But it must at the very
least annihilate the shared
eigenfunction.
True?
Consider two operators
of the following form.
who commutator ab
is equal to the identity
times a constant.
Do these operators share
any common eigenfunctions?
They can't, because the
commutator-- the identity--
doesn't annihilate
any wave functions.
Any functions.
Nothing is 0 when acted
upon by the identity.
That's the definition
of the identity.
The identity takes any function,
gives it that function back.
Cool?
Do a and b share any
common eigenfunctions?
Now let's think about what that
means in terms of observables.
Observables are
represented by operators.
What is the meaning
of the eigenfunctions
of those operators?
AUDIENCE: It corresponds
to the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It
corresponds to the state
with a definite value
of that observable.
And the value is the
corresponding eigenvalue.
So the eigenfunction of
an observable operator
is a possible state
with a definite value
of that operator.
If I tell you that I have
a state which is an energy
eigenfunction,
then that means it
is a state with a definite
value of the energy.
If I measure that energy, I
know exactly what I will get.
Cool?
If a and b are two observables
and their commutator
is proportional to the
identity, is it possible
that there is a state
with a definite value
of a and a definite value
of b simultaneously?
No, because a state with
a definite value of a
would be an eigenfunction of a.
And a state with a
definite value of b
would be an eigenfunction of b.
And there are no common states,
no common eigenfunctions
of a and b because the
commutator never kills a state.
It has no 0's.
What is the
commutator of x and p?
Commit this to memory, i h bar.
Now when we write i h bar,
this is not really an operator.
That's a number.
What's the operator?
The identity.
Are there any states which are
simultaneously eigenfunctions
of x-- the operator x--
and eigenfunctions of p?
Are there any states that
have a definite position
and a definite momentum
simultaneously?
Is that because we're ignorant?
Are we ignorant?
Yes, OK good.
So it is because
the kinds of things
that position [INAUDIBLE] r
forbid the existence of a state
with a definite value of x
and with a definite value of p
simultaneously.
It is neither here, nor
there, nor both, nor neither.
So this tells us
something very lovely.
This tells us that if we're in
a state with a definite value
of x, what must be true of our
uncertainty in the value of p?
It can't be 0, because if our
uncertainty in the knowledge p
were 0, that would mean
we were in a p eigenstate.
We would have
definite value of p.
So if a delta x is 0, delta
p cannot be 0 for sure.
Now how big does it have to be?
Could it be arbitrarily small?
So here's a
commutation relation.
You will prove the
following relation
later on in the course.
But I want to tell
you now, because I
want to give you some intuition
for what the commutator is.
What it means.
What the physics of it is.
If I take two
operators, a and b,
which have a commutator--
which is a constant times
the identity-- then the
uncertainty in any state
psi of a times the uncertainty
in the same state psi of b
must be greater than or equal
to 1/2 the absolute value
of the expectation value
of the commutator-- that's
an amazing set of
symbols-- of a with b.
Square root.
AUDIENCE: You've got yo
take the square root.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was kidding.
PROFESSOR: So the easier
way to-- let's see a,b.
Let's just make sure
I'm getting this right.
I'm the commutator of a and b.
Oh no, no.
There's no square root.
Sorry.
Why are you messing with me?
Expectation value of a and b.
Delta a.
Delta p.
H bar.
Yes, good.
So in particular, these
expectation values
should be taken
with the state psi.
Sorry, it's late and I'm tired.
And this should be
taken into state psi.
So we compute the commutator.
We take the expectation
value in our state.
We take the norm,
multiply it by 1/2,
and this is the bound
This is the claim.
So let's check this in
the case of x and p.
And do I have this
using just math?
This will come from
just linear algebra.
So let's check this in
the case of x and p.
What's the commutator?
1.
So what's the expectation
value in a state, psi,
of i h bar times operator 1 psi?
It's i h bar.
Great.
So what happens over here?
What do we get for delta x
in the state psi times delta
p in the state psi?
This must be greater than
or equal to 1/2 times
the absolute value
of the expectation
value of the commutator.
But the expectation value of
the commutator is i h bar.
And the norm of
that is just h bar.
This is the
uncertainty relation.
So given some
uncertainty in delta x,
this tells us how
much delta p is.
Now, how does this
right hand side
depend on the wave function psi?
It turns out it doesn't.
It's explicitly independent
of the particular wave
function we're interested in.
For any wave
function whatsoever,
the uncertainty in x
times the uncertainty in p
must be greater than
or equal to 1/2 h bar.
And this is a consequence
of the commutation,
and more importantly,
the failure
of x and p to commute, because
the ability to commute and get
0 is necessary for there
to be common eigenstates.
Now imagine in this case a and
b are that a and b that in fact
do share a common eigenstate.
So let's compute the uncertainty
of a in the state phi sub
ab, phi sub ab, phi
sub ab, phi sub ab.
And what is this equal to?
Well, what's the commutator
acting on the state phi sub ab?
0.
So this is greater
than or equal to 0.
And in fact, you can
just check by going
through the proof of this
that it's just equal to 0.
So what's the uncertainty of a?
Well, we know it's in the
state with definite value of a.
0.
Uncertainty in b in this
state, what's the uncertainty?
0.
We know that it's in
an eigenstate of b.
So 0 is indeed greater
than or equal to 0,
so it satisfies the
uncertainty relation.
Commuting is telling you about
the possibility of the state
having definite values of
both operators simultaneously.
And this is going to turn out
to be enormously valuable when
we talk about angular
momentum, which
is coming in a couple of weeks.
OK, see you guys on Thursday
here for the midterm.